afternoon y'all good
happily um we're all storytellers at
different points in our lives we've all
told stories in different ways and
different scenarios whether you've been
a parent tangled up telling a child a
bedtime story in a desperate bid to make
them go asleep whether you've been a
friend telling a friend
not about another friend's drunken
antics that we can to make yourself seem
slightly less embarrassed whether you've
been at a party and you've been telling
a story in order to try and impress the
redhead in the corner and you regale a
tale of by this time you were very witty
and snappy and this verbal encounter you
had with another person but you weren't
really that funny or snappy in reality
you only thought up your comebacks in
the car on the way home but she doesn't
need to know that she's on her third
martini she's ready to go we all tell
stories in different ways as well when
my when my dad tells stories he straight
to the point it's all the facts no
frills this happened then that's
happened then this happened
therefore this happened moral of the
story is don't drink tequila with your
mother otherwise you happen when my dad
tells the story when my mum tells a
story she likes to add in all the extra
details all the back stories all the
character biographies and by the end of
it it's been like a nine-hour version of
Inception you're not really sure what's
happened you just know that apparently
someone your mom works with is a bit of
a cow
when my grandparents tell stories they
tell fit-up they tell stories the way
old people tell stories they're very
humble they don't like to brag it's
always stuff like all yelling you know
and then I got my medal from Winston
Churchill from saving all those orphans
but enough about me how was school
children of the opposite when my
brothers tell stories they do the thing
all children to which is they have so
much enthusiasm and excitement that they
promise a story that's never going to
live up to your expectations and then
and then and then what happened and then
then we went outside and they were
happen and they Mathews it and then will
happen very far it great 90% of stories
my brothers have ever told me has always
ended with an unpleasant bodily function
everyone is a storyteller even in the
media television newspapers tabloids
podcasts music artists everything is a
different way of telling a story I tell
stories definitely as well I'm a
comedian I tell stories they're punchy
and jokey all the way through just in
order to keep an audience's ever
shortening attention span solely focused
on me I tell true stories I tell
exaggerated stories I told stories that
are completely and utterly made up total
lies like I'll have been sitting around
with my friends having a drink and one
of them will say something like ah
wouldn't it be funny if this happened
and I'll think to myself yeah that would
be funny and then I shamelessly take it
dynamite and my iPhone take it home
right out and somehow manage to
integrate myself into the story so I
become a hero so therefore I can then go
onstage in front of a roomful of
strangers in a desperate bid to get them
to like me because that's all a comedian
is we're desperate storytellers all we
do is go out to a roomful of people
we've never made and beg them to like us
so if at any point you're wondering why
I agreed to do this talk that's why
and also because my mum told me that if
I turn down the opportunity to do a TED
talk she'd put me up for adoption I'm 22
years old I don't know how she'd go
about that but it's best not to argue
with her when she's been drinking you
see that that was a perfect example I
made that entirely up
I made that entire just so half of you
in yeah I was willing to fabricate a
story about my mother being an alcoholic
with an emotional problem who was
willing to disown me as a human being
just so 50 of you in very good that's
what I mean by desperate story Taylor
and the thing is we're the only
storytellers though that really get in
trouble for our stories every few weeks
will be another thing in the newspaper
about this comedian that said something
awful or offensive that has a faint at
one member of the audience who by the
way nine times out of ten is an idiot
and then they talk about it on the news
and everything they get scientists and
doctors to come on and analyze the joke
interview the traumatized audience
member and then they all sit down and
discuss at length a joke which lasted
one minute and an hour-long set and we
all set patiently and wait for the
officials to tell us whether we were
offended or not and then in the end of
it they decide that we are offended and
the perhaps the comedian shouldn't talk
about rape or murder or all those sort
of things on stage that they shouldn't
be broke us in the household and we all
feel quite good about ourselves and then
with the other we then switch over to
East Anders or True Blood with their
scenes of murder sexual audacity drug
abuse racially involved crimes and we
all go this is our maize egg why is it
different how come when a comedian says
something is a joke it's offensive but
when it's acted out in front of you it's
intriguing it's a twist
actors are never criticized or abused
for their roles in films nobody came out
of inglorious basterds going oh my god I
can't believe Christopher Walt's killed
all those Jewish people what an awful
man nobody came out of Harry Potter
thinking well you know what I never
trusted Snape to begin with not since he
had that awful German accent and tried
to kill John McClane
there you go people don't get upset
because they know it's fake
they know the actors on stage are just
portraying characters so our comedians
that's our job we're storytellers but
we're also so vain that we like to put
ourselves in the stories where the
writers directors and stars of our own
show where we're just playing an
exaggerated parody of ourselves cause
we're not going to be ourselves onstage
we might play a version of ourselves but
we can be our true selves if we were to
come on stage and talk to you about our
real opinions with balance thought
through points we wouldn't be comedians
we would be politicians and you'd hate
us even more right when we come on stage
we have to do we have to do find ways to
make it laugh and our ways of doing that
is to come out and say something
completely stupid and ludicrous to make
you laugh another method of doing it is
to take a completely an early point that
no one would agree with something very
obscure and blatantly wrong and find a
way to twist it round and make it seem
valid just for a second for example if I
were to make the statement
I don't think children should smoke
everyone in this room would agree we
yeah but if I were to come on stage now
I would say I think every child under
the age of 13 should be forced to smoke
four packets of cigarettes a day because
as my brothers are getting older it
turns out they're very close to being
able to beat me in a footrace that's a
way of turning it around you're not
laughing at the fact that I'm trying to
kill my brothers you're laughing at me
for being an idiot for thinking that's a
good idea
okay and that's what we do with our
comedy we're playing stupid versions of
ourselves for example if Ricky Gervais
is Frankie Boyle or Jimmy Carr or
actually as big as the bigoted racist
fascist homophobic sexist that the Daily
Mail made them out to be they would
probably end up working for the Daily
Mail
they're making this stuff up to get that
reaction from you the reason those three
names Frank you've already raised in
Jimmy Carr is they're three the names
more commonly associated with a faint of
comedy now the reason I put a faint of
comedy and inverted commas there isn't
because I'm young and hip it's because
basically I don't really get the term of
feints of comedy no comedian wants to
offend you that's not our job our job is
to make you laugh make you think make
you smile make you want to sleep with us
so that our night in that hotel room is
slightly less depressing not to upset
you in any way shape or form form
because the thing about it is when
comedians are telling these stories it's
to get any form of a reaction if you and
Jimmy Carr famously was in trouble
recently he made a joke about the
Paralympics I mean a joke that our trips
in Iraq were getting injured but at
least that would make us have a good
Paralympic team and people went mental
our people were so upset if you were to
believe the tabloids trains stopped on
the track so that people could get off
in order to vomit how disgusted they
were by this joke people killed
themselves they were sort of scattering
what he said right that's not the case
Billy Billy who weren't offended by that
joke the war veterans who found it
hysterical are they thought was very
they repeated it to each other so if
they weren't offended by that joke who's
got the right to be offended people have
developed an amazing new ability
recently people can be offended on
behalf of other people you can't be
offended on behalf of someone feelings
are non-transferable you can't be a
husband standing beside a wife giving
birth going don't worry honey I'm
feeling pain on behalf of you she would
beat you to death
nobody asked these people to be offended
on behalf of them they just did it
themselves they jumped in front of a
bullet that was heading towards a tree
right it was it was a blatantly stupid
sacrifice they never needed to make it's
amazing one of the other topics but one
of more controversial ones last year was
there
Frankie Boyle made his air comments
about Kate price and her family and
regards about Europeans on the job which
everyone will be divided on don't pay
that context you have to understand that
Frankie Boyle make those jokes up
bout Katie Price not to her about her he
made that joke onstage in front of a
roomful of people who were fully
expecting him to make that sort of
comment it wasn't until the newspapers
phoned up Katie Price and repeated to
that joke to her several times in order
to get a reaction that's when she knew
about it I am fully aware that there are
many people out there in the world who
don't like me
who say mean things about me every day
but I'd rather not know okay if you came
out to me and you told me that there was
a man that I'd never met before who was
saying horrible things about me and then
you then listed all the awful things
he'd said about me to my face you're the
bad guy that person has a right to see
whatever he wants about me I've never
met before but he can say whatever you
want that's his right it wasn't until
you told me that I knew it was going on
you've turned it into a personal attack
and most of the time when committees are
making jokes with these celebrities and
celebrity culture it's no different from
stuff you hear from groups of frames the
banner that we have every day with our
makes about someone a celebrity on
television that we don't particularly
like are you trying to suggest that
celebrities don't nor the ridicule by
the general public that Katie Price
thinks that Frankie Boyle is the only
comedian that doesn't respect her life
choices no of course we're just
individuals who are willing to risk
going onstage saying what everyone else
down the pub was saying on a Friday
night
it seems the general public can say
whatever they want about celebrities but
comedians can't and that's hypocrisy
that's not fair there is a market for
shock comedy a huge market okay but
there's also a market for legging
sadomasochism and Justin Bieber all
arguably more offensive than anything
anyone's ever said and I'm not trying to
say that you shouldn't be offended or
upset by things I'm in no position to
tell you what should and shouldn't upset
you that is your right to react whoever
you want but we comedians also have a
right a right to say whatever we want to
make our audience laugh and get the
reaction that we want we're fortunate
enough to live in a society where
there's loads of Carlino these comedies
bigger than it's ever been so if you
don't like one Telex type of comedy you
can go see another one everything's
cared for but we should be allowed to do
whatever makes our
audience laughs not people that weren't
there the audience that paid to come see
us that traveled around the world and
country sometimes to come and see us to
do what we do without having to worry
that there's someone in the audience who
might take one of our jokes out of
context and then repeat it because most
of the time the jokes are taken out of
context you know you're not you're only
given the brutal punchline you're only
told the joke by a news presenter with
her sour face just repeating it that's
not how it was delivered you're not
given the context you're not getting the
setup you're not given the atmosphere
you're not even given the audience
reaction and that's not fair you don't
take other storyteller stories their
context if I were to tell you that when
I was 5 years old my dad would tell me a
story about a mass murderer who would
disguise himself as a close relative in
order to get close to a young girl so
that he could have his way with her and
just before he managed to do that he was
brutally murdered everyone agree that my
dad is dreadful man but if I were to
point out that that's the basic
storyline for a little red riding-hood
a lot less people are fawning child
services
okay you know how what was intended to
be delivered and you expected it that
way right a story is just a story and a
joke is just a joke you knew the stories
that you heard as a kid weren't true
right there was no monster under the bed
no boogeyman in the corner your granddad
wasn't really ripping off its thumb and
taking the pain exceptionally well he
was just doing it please apply the same
logic to our stories we're saying these
jokes as jokes there's very rarely in
tain malicious intent behind it there
may not be jokes that you're like what
we're doing is we're taking a concept
and we're exaggerating it lying about it
turning it in such a way that you
weren't expecting it and sometimes we
turn out in a way that you don't like
but that's your problem the world
doesn't revolve around you ignore it
move on forget about it right you seem
to assume that comedians haven't gone
through any hardships whereas most the
time it's a hardship that's caused us to
get into comedy our reaction to our
hardship was to make light of the
situation get over it as opposed to
going around the country making sure
that nobody ever mentioned it ever again
to hurt my delicate soul so that's my
point that's the point I'm trying to
make and if at any point you have agreed
with anything I have said doing this
don't
it was just a story I made it all up
thank you very much